[Musique]
les phénomènes critiques s'accélèrent
disent à 15% de moins sur les recharges
de nappe par exemple c'est absolument
fondamental on a travaillé sur tous les
sujets sur le sujet quantitatif
qualitatif le petit cycle le Grand Cycle
l'objectif c'est de simplifier peut-être
un petit peu les choses à travers le
rapport qu'on a fait puis vous savez que
le Sénat c'est quand même le
représentant à la fois des collectivités
mais aussi des territoires et on a fait
un travail qui concerne nos territoires
améliorer la connaissance de la
ressource et des prélèvements parce que
si on veut négocier sur le partage de
l'eau il faut que tous les acteurs
soient bien au courant de ce que l'on
peut utiliser et comment on l'utilise
donc ça c'est absolument fondamental
améliorer bien sûr la gouvernance mais
améliorer aussi les stratégies
territoriales pour que la politique de
l'eau soit gérée à tous les niveaux du
grand jusqu'au plus petit des
territoires en essayant en même temps
d'améliorer les politiques publiques
d'accompagnement à la fois des
communautés de communes des métropoles
des départements et des régions sur 53
propositions il faut en retenir
quelques-unes la médiation par les
comités de bassin où il y a des
problématiques de partage de l'eau de
conflits d'usage de faire en sorte que
il y ait un médiateur qui serait le
comité de bassin et si le comité de
bassin toutefois n'arrive pas à trouver
une solution dans la médiation ce serait
le Comité national de l'eau le CNE qui
prendrait le relais au niveau national
pour trouver une solution on parle
beaucoup d'évaporation importante j'ai
proposé qu'on incite parfois à faire du
photovoltaïque sur les retenues de
substitution pour limiter l'évaporation
au maximum on a audité sur un spectre
très large et ce rapport va vraiment en
profondeur sur un grand nombre de sujets
et je pense que c'est un outil
intéressant et vraiment efficace pour
traduire d'une manière pragmatique
vraiment factuelle des orientations
gouvernementales qui manquait peut-être
parfois un peu justement d'approche
concrètes pour mettre en œuvre ses
mesures